this is Startalk are there any good
viruses and what do they do yeah yeah so
we heard about bad viruses there's gotta
be some all viruses can't be bad no no
there are there are several there are
people who are now using viruses to
introduce genes for people who have
disorders like Alzheimer's and diabetes
and Parkinson's so now using viruses to
make vaccines and there's a very cool
yes the viruses are cleverer than we are
about how to make that happen well we
know we engineer them we put things into
them use them as delivery vehicles right
because they know how to get in a virus
and mess with a DNA in ways that we
can't right and they can produce some
product that's useful and there are
people who are making using viruses now
to purify things like gold and to make
electric circuits so they're being used
now for nanotechnology so viruses are
very interesting so this is the base we
can use a virus to make better gold
sounds safe and you can make viruses
that was specifically bind to gold or
platinum and you can flow seawater over
them and capture it and concentrate it
Wow
yeah so viruses viruses is our future
and you've never you ever steal a virus
and put it in someone's soup not like a
deadly one but just like I don't like
you and I'm gonna make you sick first
and they tend to die in soup well maybe
a good sponsor of that cold solution
I'll help you think of a solution so the
future of our biologists is one not only
of curing disease but of transforming
life where alchemy left off biology
picks up apparently yes he said he
answered yes to that question I know
it's true viruses are great they're the
best I'm gonna get my bag of viruses and
sit through it asking the questions
you